The covariance between
two random variables
tells us something
about the strength
of the dependence between them.
But it is not so easy to
interpret qualitatively.
For example, if I tell you
that the covariance of X and Y
is equal to 5, this
does not tell you
very much about whether X and
Y are closely related or not.
Another difficulty is that
if X and Y are in units,
let's say, of meters,
then the covariance
will have units
of meters squared.
And this is hard to interpret.
A much more informative quantity
is the so-called correlation
coefficient, which is
a dimensionless version
of the covariance.
It is defined by
this formula here.
We just take the
covariance and divide it
by the product of the
standard deviations of the two
random variables.
Now, if X has units of meters,
then the standard deviation
also has units of meters.
And so this ratio
will be dimensionless.
And it is not affected by
the units that we're using.
The same is true
for this ratio here,
and this is why the correlation
coefficient does not
have any units of its own.
One remark-- if we're dealing
with a random variable whose
standard deviation
is equal to 0--
so its variance is
also equal to 0--
then we have a random
variable, which
is identically
equal to a constant.
Well, for such cases of
degenerate random variables,
then the correlation
coefficient is not
defined, because it would
have involved a division by 0.
A very important property of
the correlation coefficient
is the following.
It turns out that the
correlation coefficient
is always between minus 1 and 1.
And this allows us to judge
whether a certain correlation
coefficient is big or
not, because we now
have an absolute scale.
And so it does provide a measure
of the degree to which two
random variables are associated.
To interpret the
correlation coefficient,
let's now look at
some extreme cases.
Suppose that X and
Y are independent.
In that case, we know
that the covariance
is going to be equal to 0.
And therefore, the
correlation coefficient
is also going to be equal to 0.
And in that case, we say
that the two random variables
are uncorrelated.
However, the converse
statement is not true.
We have seen already
an example in which we
have zero covariance and
therefore zero correlation,
but yet the two random
variables were dependent.
Let us now look at
the other extreme,
where the two
random variables are
as dependent as they can be.
So let's look at the
correlation coefficient
of one random
variable with itself.
What is it going to be?
The covariance of a random
variable with itself
is just the variance of
that random variable, now,
sigma X is going to be
the same as sigma Y,
because we're taking
Y to be the same as X.
So we're dividing
by sigma X squared.
But the square of the standard
deviation is the variance.
So we obtain a value of 1.
So a correlation
coefficient of 1
shows up in such a case
of an extreme dependence.
If instead we had taken the
correlation coefficient of X
with the negative
of X, in that case,
we would have obtained a
correlation coefficient
of minus 1.
A somewhat more
general situation
than the one we considered
here is the following.
If we have two
random variables that
have a linear relationship--
that is, if I know Y
I can figure out the value
of X with absolute certainty,
and I can figure it out
by using a linear formula.
In this case, it turns out that
the correlation coefficient
is either plus 1 or minus 1.
And the converse is true.
If the correlation coefficient
has absolute value of 1,
then the two random
variables obey
a deterministic linear
relation between them.
So to conclude, an extreme value
for the correlation coefficient
of plus or minus 1 is
equivalent to having
a deterministic relation
between the two random variables
involved.
A final remark about
the algebraic properties
of the correlation
coefficient- What can we
say about the
correlation coefficient
of a linear function of a
random variable with another?
Well, we already know
something about what
happens to the covariance when
we form a linear function.
And the covariance of aX plus
b with Y is related this way
to the covariance of X with Y.
Now, let us use this property
and calculate the correlation
coefficient between aX
plus b and Y.
In the numerator, we
have the covariance of aX
plus b with Y, which
is equal to a times
the covariance of X with
Y. At the denominator,
we have the standard deviation
of this random variable.
Now, the standard deviation
of this random variable
is equal to a times the
standard deviation of X,
if a is positive.
If a is negative, then we
need to put the minus sign.
But in either case, we will
have here the absolute value
of a times the
standard deviation
of X. And then we divide
by the standard deviation
of the second random
variable, which is Y.
And so what we obtain
here is this ratio, which
is a correlation coefficient
of X with Y times
this quantity, which
is the sign of a.
So we have the sign of a times
the correlation coefficient
of X with Y. So in
particular, the magnitude
of the correlation
coefficient is not
going to change when we
replace X by aX plus b.
And this essentially
means that if we
change the units of
the random variable X,
for example, suppose
that X was degrees
Celsius and aX plus b is
degrees Fahrenheit, going
from one set of units,
Celsius degrees,
to another set of units,
degrees in Fahrenheit,
is not going to
change the correlation
coefficient of the temperature
with some other random
variable.
So this is a nice property of
the correlation coefficient,
again, which reflects the
fact that it's dimensionless,
it doesn't have any
units of its own,
and it doesn't depend
on what kinds of units
we use for each one of
the random variables.